check out this story from ABC News
Twitter sends meta cease and desist
letter over new threads app say sources
now this is confirmed Elon Musk has even
uh called it out he said competition is
fine cheating is not Twitter Daily News
tweet uh tweeting Twitter is threatening
to sue meta over systematic willful and
unlawful misappropriation of Twitter's
Trade Secrets and IP as well as scraping
of Twitter's data in a cease and desist
letter sent yesterday to Zuckerberg by
elon's lawyer Alex Spiro I have to
wonder recently we heard that Twitter
was limiting how much how many tweets
you could see and they said it's because
people were stealing data I wonder if
it's because Elon found out meta was
actually scraping data to use for their
new app I mean Mark Zuckerberg doing
something untoward in regard to like
intellectual property that doesn't sound
right guys Mark Zuckerberg wouldn't do
that it's not like he has a history of
that with the very creation of Facebook
to be fair his his history of trying to
create rival alternative social media
platforms has not fared too well
they tried to do a signal type thing
didn't work out they tried to do a
Snapchat type thing didn't work out I am
pretty sure threads will not work out
look man it might but it is a really bad
platform there are people on the left to
our tribally just saying woo it's so
much better and I'm just like dude
you log into the app let me let me I'm
going to log in right now I'm gonna I'm
gonna pull it up and I'm gonna I'm gonna
I'm gonna like so first of all it's
recommending AOC to me like crazy I do
not follow AOC on this and uh let's
let's see what what it wants me to so
there are people I follow
and uh I do see their posts okay what's
this puberty what is what pubity I've
seen puppet the largest and most
populated city on earth Tokyo Japan
that's a cool picture I don't care
that's I I followed them on Instagram
where I at least get recommended them a
lot I think they're just like a general
interest kind of yeah now this or
something Paris Hilton oh that's great
uh let's see complex magazine don't know
what that is Ellen DeGeneres not
interested I don't know who that person
is I don't know who that person is like
these are these are people posting
things about like their day that have
nothing like I'm getting recommended the
dude who made threads I don't care about
this look my whole feed look at this
like none of it is people I follow
so micro gang tweets the threads from
Microsoft yo
I don't want to look at a feat of random
advertisements that's what it is it's
all ads it's the algorithm saying here's
something you might like here's
something I don't like it I don't like
it what am I supposed to do you can't
turn it off is when when you sign up for
Threads does it connect to your Facebook
account you can have it connect to your
your Instagram so how do you download it
anyway I think you go to well it's in
the play store but I had to go to
threads.net to download it is it called
threads it's like threads comma a meta
app or something like this it's
recommending me Ted Cruz okay I don't
follow Ted Cruz or AOC at least it's not
just AOC Jubilee media what is this one
the Blaze TV I don't follow the blaze
seriously they get suspended all the
time so it is weird that it's
recommending The Blaze to me I don't I
don't I look that's not the least of it
it's it's very limited in what's what's
available to do on the platform but
here's here there's the one thing I said
on threads as to why it's not that good
look I don't care what my favorite
nature photographer has to say
at all
like I don't follow people on Instagram
I follow people who play poker I follow
people who skateboard who who uh scoot
who BMX uh some nature like a couple
like travel people and some Parkour
people I'm not an Instagram for a news
feed so when I start threads and it's
like here are the people you follow it's
like oh sure like I follow prageru for
and a few people for some of their
political stuff but it's mostly not
here's ultimately what I think and the
reason why I bring up the algorithmic
feed
I think what the powers that be feared
the most in terms of social media was
curated feeds which created tribes and
hives
people go on Twitter they follow only
the opinions they like and they create
these bubbles where they separate
themselves from everybody else I think
what Instagram wants to do what Mark
Zuckerberg wants to do
uh YouTube does the same thing they want
to eliminate the ability for you to
create a curated feed this has been sure
on YouTube Forever subscriptions on
YouTube are completely meaningless and
have been for 10 years everybody knows
that when you say homepage yeah when you
subscribe to a channel it doesn't matter
you're not going to get fed that content
it's going to be whatever's on the home
page so YouTube chooses if you're
actually there and gives this this
impression that your you know your
subscriber count matters but it really
doesn't really doesn't
Instagram meta they want to do the same
thing with Twitter
so that when you sign up for Threads
they are really hoping that it does shut
down Twitter and then this is what the
future will be you will be forced to
follow the likes of The Young Turks
you'll be forced to follow the likes of
AOC or Ted Cruz
perhaps they think it'll be a healing
thing to bring the sides together so
that everyone will have a shared
narrative but let's be real they've
already censored DC Drano if you try to
fight there was a post where they were
showing if you tried to follow him it
warns you that he's fake news we know
exactly where it's going you're going to
follow conservative and libertarian
disrupted liberals those are going to
get de-ranked without you knowing
they're going to prop up people like AOC
and neocon's you know acceptable
Republican personalities Ted Cruz for
instance and they're going to try to
excise the likes of you know anyone
outside the political machine big
problem for me with centralized media in
general is part of why I don't like this
idea that elon's been pushing to create
an app for everything a One-Stop app the
X app because if Elon doesn't like you
Alex Jones he can just ban you from
everything then if you're putting
everything through a central server same
with metamam too much power the DC Drano
gotta already put on a list or was on a
list I don't like it man I don't like it
well they can't force people to get out
of their silos you got to let them do it
on their own you gotta Inspire them to
do it the only in interest I would have
an alternative to Twitter is even more
free speech because like you said Elon
he's not totally he has this personal
Vendetta against Alex Jones I actually
think that it's he doesn't want to get
banned from the App Store but it's more
unpopular to say that than to say oh I
just have a very strong opinion about
his uh treatment of the Sandy Hook
people but in any case you're not going
to get more free speech from anything
Mark Zuckerberg owns than something that
Elon Musk owns so in my opinion why I
mean I can understand what if you're a
leftist and you want more content
moderation you'd rather have a threads
conversation than a Twitter conversation
because the moderation is going to be
more what you're looking for but I mean
for people like DC Drano it doesn't it
it's it's never going to be as free as
Twitter is you know what'll make the
magic if threads and Twitter come
together and cooperate and you can
threads has stated they will soon be on
the Theta verse so this is actually
really interesting I think the fediverse
is a very very important move for social
media that can actually fix a lot of the
problems for those aren't familiar it's
effectively
the internet of social media so imagine
this imagine early early internet to go
to a website you're like you log into
AOL and then AOL shows you a list of
things you can click but there are
websites of course
today you have Twitter you have Facebook
you have YouTube you can go on that
platform and see people with the
fediverse all of these different apps
will interlock with each other so you
can go onto threads and see someone's
tweet you could see someone's blue sky
post someone's masted on post someone's
Gap post so that that's actually a very
very good thing however if that is the
case there's no reason to use threads
because it's a Zuckerberg platform you
might as well just use any of the other
fataverse apps but that that stops
censorship if if we can get a Twitter
like system if we can get Federated
networks what happens is you might sign
up for Threads because it's easy
you can see posts from Phil on Twitter
and then you can you know threads might
be like we're blocking Twitter from from
our Network because we don't like him
but Phil can then sign up for any other
fediverse app or connect it that way and
Syndicate so ultimately you can't be
censored in fact you can even create
your own website with your own protocol
where you can never be banned because
your username would be like Ian at Ian
crossland.net or whatever so then people
would just follow you from your website
so it's kind of like RSS feeds turning
Twitter into a network of servers
instead of one centralized platform so
that's good
but yeah there's actually these things
called ens domains ens it's ethereum
Network server names I believe it's they
think it might be like your ID on the uh
web 3.0 and you go to like ens dot
domains
um but you buy it with crypto and it's
like you can use your name.eath eth
which is the ethereum thing you use pay
ethereum for it that might be one way to
have like a a presence that can that can
bounce around from Network to network or
or you control your own because it'll be
like a wallet where you have your money
and your ID all together where you can
log into all these different sites and
imagine if nobody could ban you because
nobody owns your server all they can do
is block you that's the way it should be
the problem now is with threads or
Twitter or any other platform there's
some dude who's like I'm just gonna ban
you you can't do that in the real world
you can't get banned from like walking
down the street and saying your opinions
you know to a certain or the phone
company it Can't Ban you right to a
certain degree you can of course because
people lie cheat and steal all the time
and you know corrupt government
officials will try and play dirty games
the point is we are protected and
expressing our opinions I hope that's
where this all goes and uh I don't know
what Jack Dorsey is working on but I
just want to give a shout out to Jack
Dorsey because he recently did a podcast
interview where he said that JFK was
assassinated by the CIA and he like got
very into it and he's like so you're
saying it's like he's like yours at that
point was when the American dream was
stripped away when our own government
the CIA killed a sitting president I was
like wait what what why would you act
yeah wait didn't they basically admit
that
I know Tucker's said it Ron Paul said it
like we're at the point where basically
it is a it is it is maybe I'm too far
down the conspiracy rabbit hole for too
many things where I'm just like yeah I
thought we were all on the same page
like yes I love the Kennedy conspiracy
assassination conspiracy because I there
are people who say it's multiple gunmen
you know and it's Lee Harvey Oswald it's
all pinned on this one guy but like
The Story of Lee Harvey Oswald's crazy
first he screamed out I'm a patsy as
they were carrying him away they found
his gun in the building that he was in
like on another floor so like if you're
gonna go gets killed yeah and then
someone comes up and kills him but like
if you're gonna commit that crime you
wouldn't like put your gun in a room and
go upstairs and have lunch afterwards
who in their right mind but I did not
want to ignite
that conversation just shouting out Jack
Dorsey because I saw that clip but the
point is you know he made Blue Sky I do
want to say one thing on the one last
thing before we move on
there's a there's a funny post I saw
where uh this Twitter user said it is
2023 and I'm joining Mastodon it is 2023
and I am joining Blue Sky it is 2023 and
I am joining threads and it's a picture
of Dr Manhattan from Watchmen like
sitting on Mars I just thought that was
really good I'm like you guys stop
trying it's not gonna work threads is
already censoring things yeah that's you
can't curate your feed
the point of Twitter is that it is where
we are angry with each other that's it
sorry have a nice well I mean because
Mastodon that was already the left-wing
alternatively bound to fail just because
it doesn't it's not an easy thing yeah I
did try to log on and create an account
just so I could kind of see what the
leftists were talking about it was not
very intuitive and I'm kind of a boomer
I'll admit but still it wasn't nearly as
easy as Twitter but I think even the
leftists who claim that they want all
the you know the quote right-wing
extremist banned they know that Twitter
is fun because of that conflict that but
they can't stay away so here's what I
think the right wants to debate the left
they want to have this big conversation
the left wants to ban everyone on the
right
the thing is Twitter is the water cooler
it is the Town Square so the left wants
the right band from it so they have a
monopoly on the narrative the right
wants to use the platform to engage in
debate it does not work for either if
the other leaves if these liberals and
leftists leave and go to Mastodon
they're no longer in Town Square they
have no narrative control there's no
point being there sure you've banned all
the conservatives but now you have no
influence right for conservatives if
there's no one to talk to but each other
it's boring there's no debate truth well
they want the conservatives right the
leftists want the conservatives on the
platform so they're able to feed the
conservatives what they want them to see
they don't want conservatives in their
own Echo chamber because then they're
going to be talking about the leftists
in a way that they don't like thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time